so thomas what would you like to
do when you get bigger names
they win a look years and more i
drop you ready for semi finals
because i was supporting more tomorrow
by thomas these lists still remained
in the depths of the rankings
without ever managing to come back to the
fore either they are a bit there all but
verbal
[Music]
aged all however I'm going to play the
qualifiers
this time you're a guy I'm not giving up if
you had won the match earlier three
males complexion tired you  so according to my
calculations I can still play seven years
[Music]
you know the thomas edison knee so will
face asbestos on the jump
[Music]
we still made ten members to
take because it's going to be a good shot but
turn d  'fake warm-up will
therefore continue to play next year maybe
you promised me to occupy all the space
you think I thought I had a
chance to pass the qualifiers
so you do not believe me capable
to reach a pre  part time
[Music]
damn what's your strategy against everyone
mentally strongest
[Music]
it's very hard
thomas edison
I know what I have to do it's not
thomas edison 37 euros he knows he  did
n't finish
[Music]